[Music]
what is the strangest possible name you
think a baby could have abcdefg a little
pee
tiger Deuteronomy Deuteronomy yeah
[ __ ] Windows right hmm
it's pretty football [ __ ] let's
think let's [ __ ] up more like what
we're um moister benadryl was a good one
there was a controversy a while back in
Japan with these parents that wanted to
name their kids Satan wow I love that
one but it's Japanese word for Satan
site Don just some time oh I'm Satan's
yeah from Satan like from the Bible say
say devil well this guy here he won a
pizza contest because of his name being
so strange
come on honey first of all can I ask
what is a pizza contest yeah what is a
pizza like a pizza eating or pizza
making so I will assume the contest is
whoever has the weirdest name gets like
free pizza oh you know it would be
awesome feel free but I thought it was
[ __ ] hilarious that the prizes you
could get two large pepperoni pizzas for
49 vessels looks like a wait is it even
in Mexico okay wait wait wait wait the
Spanish name avocado chancla what's a
pizza contest in Mexico I think you have
to see if your dick skin matches the the
color of the pepperoni pizza but what's
the contest part the cod this is the
weirdest weird name oh I see it so that
was real 100 to Tory salt no pendejo
[Laughter]
you don't know wait you don't sound like
regular nicknames do ya know okay how
about you guys stop thinking of word
words like black so this let's not burn
well I mean technically his name is a I
not letters oh-oh-oh-oh
hashtag no but the closest oh no no this
siguiente Nueve no sixteen a sequin oh
sometimes oh [ __ ] okay well his name is
zero zero three whoa is he from a
[ __ ] lab with little petals that's
what does that mean he's a Mexican
incubating babe that's his like it's
either Third Age those guys all died
yeah bad already
don't let that office Doble settle this
a good number this is his name but look
the shtetl sounds kind of cool though oh
yeah so okay here's a story how do you
even slice that pizza why would you put
two zeros and not just call him three
that's the mystery
so they're saying here or he's saying
that he didn't know his his actual birth
given name until he was 15 years old his
real name Walter no that's his real name
Oh like he's currently yeah zero all
along he had been called I'm Bambino by
his parents and his friends and that's
weird too right he grew up in the United
States
oh and baby's number was 0 3 I was 6
it was not sick you know what I don't
even know if it was 6
I know I should list but he's so good
you know so much but you got to step up
I'm gonna step up my [ __ ] the 20 you
don't know what my words you know what
of a [ __ ] you're gonna go to war with
me
this is war you don't want a war you
don't wanna world you do not green oh
man do I am scared I'm scared mercury
retrograde I can't write [ __ ]
mercury retrograde happens to our
internet every week okay am i typing
okay as I continue with the story you
can I got my nothing huh
so then he so he grew up in the United
States when he went back to Mexico to
get his in me fare his rest of the
Duggars license it was three [ __ ]
baby
okay the great Bambino it was three
that's beautiful so that's why I put it
together that's really dope that's
awesome dude anyway anyways anyways
anyways anyways so then that's when he
needed to hand in his birth certificate
and that's when he saw on his birth
certificate his name is his full name is
Seto Seto threats Miller Santos Ciao
Bella
why not just call him free well the
thing is his parents ended up having
three kids he was a third kid I nailed
it but his other two he's like two
siblings they have normal names they're
not numbers they're not wanted to
they're not number it's hard picking a
name so I don't blame his parents it's
really [ __ ] hard that's yeah that's
weird man so they were just sleep panic
they know like [ __ ] I don't know don't
[ __ ] up a minute his parents robots well
what's it yeah right 0 1 0 that's the
hit they're Mexican robots
dude that's 11 my parents they were
[ __ ] there they don't know what to do
and then my dad saw a [ __ ] Time
magazine cover has Steve Jobs on it
really but that's a name it's not like
Brian and then Steve and then eight but
what's confusing is like okay I get like
I think it's cool that they they were
fans of Babe Ruth apparently and then uh
and then they'd name him we get it
you're right anyway yeah and like so but
the rest
sounds funny as a name settled rest is
kind of cool but why the extra so the
two other kids maybe I don't know
I don't know their thought process
they're kind of like so so they they
wanted to name him with the numbers zero
zero three but because like the system
or whatever they they didn't allow
numbers so they spelled it out oh that's
better than [ __ ] Blue Ivy that's a
long news queue blues fine but Blue
Ivy's like whoa that's what that's like
a white trash person getting pillars in
their shitty house to me like we like
Paul Steve Paul Green I don't have any
other do you I don't
are you jealous you don't have a mill
man I am you should be that's like red
Daisy you should fall about it oh I
could have given myself one
why not worried named James why didn't
you because it was in the spot like I
didn't know that I could until I was
filling out the paperwork at the Social
Security office and I was like oh I
could do this I'm like wait nurse what
would it be
didn't they oh no I don't know I had to
think about it and then it was hard
enough to name Isaac so I'm like I don't
know this is a bad decision if I try to
come up with something yeah yeah cuz
that's like getting a tattoo yeah you
gotta stick with that yeah and you can't
do it drawing do it but you can you were
drinking out the courthouse again okay
definitely drinking at your name change
but you probably shouldn't yeah he's
gonna pay for it did you want know the
reason for the name Blue Ivy did they
say why they just said [ __ ] red
dandelion like it's just a thing like a
color and a thing hormone people were
given Kanye and Kim a rough time for
North but I thought North list I thought
it was north I loved it yeah but there's
Peter North it's not a it's not a weird
name you know it's a man I've heard name
like his last name and it's a stage name
is the name that I've heard before you
know it's not you don't know Peter nor
she doesn't watch old school point she
wants a new [ __ ] old school [ __ ] better
classics kiss your head you can't get
your hands right now
Korona y-you know it's such a [ __ ]
waste that we didn't have Peter North
like advertising for products can you
imagine if people noses like hot peered
north and this [ __ ] washing machine
can get out the toughest stay here like
take it from me nobody can nobody could
blow loads like me this washing machine
can handle the toughest thickest low
like you my bet she who wouldn't buy
that [ __ ] banging embraces the point
stars back then nowadays we love our
porn stars you know yeah true we do love
them no but they used to make way more
money back then you think so oh yeah
they did
Oh cuz they were like almost looked at
as like they were like he's like almost
like a pit of studios and stuff like
baby they were rare you have to pay for
porn days so people were pay and
performed right and cuz porn was like in
theaters - what did their old theater
you go to fries no tracks and I remember
they always had the weird guy I were
like weird and they're all like getting
born from DVDs I'm like they're looking
at the back of the cover and [ __ ] [ __ ]
perp browsing that's not smart
I remember the curtain that they would
have it the movie the movie places
whatever okay let me show you guys some
more names that entered the competition
for the pizzas is there I don't
understand Spanish though varices are
names did you plyer Juke liar it's like
a surprise sing get thought I know
that's in him cero cero tress March
that's not that Chris Harris a lair
I like Joop liar oh no that's who play n
know these crazy names cute your one-way
dressing bats Bobby oh I thought that
was bad Barbie that's the body Nazi body
yeah I think the name of this place is
just as weird as all homemade pizza you
might as well take it a keyboard and go
Mike eww be why how do you pronounce
that it's PC it daddy
wavy they all seem like Pokemon pokemons
name hi I just got its webby did
yeah how to banning you isn't our names
hard to choose though when you're
picking one for yeah that's why I got
such a sick one I know you always talk
about that we got a little list for our
future potential babies yeah can we hear
any of them you know just be like they
can [ __ ] change it at 18 if they want
to change it at 18 [ __ ] nine of well
18 years our entire life actually there
was a girl I went to school with her
name was like Heather or something she
ended up teams you get to Bambi which
she was a grown up Walker she could
straight ahead for her Bambi's kind of
nice though she was known in in in
school she was hella old but she was
still picking her nose and eating her do
you like in middle school well you don't
know how good it tastes
she's like I'm more of a man bleeding
and did I eventually ended up working
with her on my first job and um I'm such
a [ __ ] I can't believe eyes his
hometown Buffon's yeah I don't have a
fake and God with her [ __ ] snot
fingers yeah like she had a nosebleed
one day and I was like girl you're
picking your nose yeah what'd you say
she was like what she's so dead no she's
like
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you